what we're doing today is we're building
a dream house and that really is a
translation of what is important to
people starts with this I mean otherwise
it's just some kind of abstract kind of
spatial artistic piece it kind of starts
with you've got people who need to be
housed or go to work or do something so
I tend to like really simple forms and
I'm intentionally choosing the same
color as the base just so it kind of
looks like there's a seamless connection
between the base and this mess the house
is really the kind of most simple type
of building one could build you know
it's basically a bed of space for a
kitchen was based for a bathroom so
because it's so simple it actually can
be a container for like really really
big ideas so the first thing that you
want to think about is your ambition
your vision of what your idea is so what
I'm trying to do and we'll see how
successfully we do this is build a house
around a library I draw inspiration from
traveling so like when I walk around I
pay attention to environments and spaces
I don't really notice people if you look
at this these are a flow of kind of
material pieces that can be built up
into something and taken apart and used
again and the future of architecture
really could should be kind of more like
this something that you kind of engage
with rather than something being hidden
so I'm sticking with a very sort of
monochromatic
color palette which is kind of very
typical of architects like these really
bright colors scare me a little bit the
yellow is a color that will stand out
the most so work of going with yellow as
our most important element today it's
not just the visual things I mean you're
kind of looking at pattern and color and
all of that but it's the way that it
feels when you kind of walk in like the
feeling of a wood floor underneath you
is radically different from a piece of
stone I mean we do have a whole regimes
of sensory input that we're subject to
every day that we don't pay that much
attention to but if you do it kind of
changes the way that you see things
design is definitely and it
process you know you kind of have to
test your ideas your first one is
usually not going to be great which is
fine
being able to iterate is absolutely
crucial to what it is we do because you
possibly cannot get it right the first
time one of the things about
architecture that's kind of fun is when
things don't go right it has to be the
thing that kind of turns your gears when
you're faced with a limit or something
you kind of stop and say hmm really does
that have to be so does that necessarily
have to be a limit creativity can tend
to come out of a lot of restrictions
just because you have to work within
that and that's common for a lot of
architecture because you're trying to
conform to a lot of like zoning
regulations and Building Code I'm also
client requirements budget like there's
so many constraints you tend to have to
be very creative with your solutions
it's really a professional all about
where you dream and then you see your
dream and your vision come to reality to
fruition and that's it's really quite
marvelous lately a lot of people who've
gotten architecture degrees have left
the profession and gone into like game
design or things like that some of
monkey's head shoe designers which ain't
trained as architects it's really
important for us to understand
architecture the way we I would
understand music the way we would
understand dance because it is the
beautiful qualities of the spaces we
live in we work in we play and it's
constantly surrounding us with Instagram
and social media there's a lot of
feature on architecture and design now
so people are starting to see it as
something of value and why it's worth
investing in most Architects that I know
you kind of see it as a calling as
something you're very passionate about
so as you imagine if someone's kind of
walking across the front of there and
I'm kind of used the colors
instrumentally but you can see the kind
of layers of the house as you move
through and now the windows are getting
a little bit smaller and smaller and
smaller so as a pedestrian walking by
the front the house doesn't feel like
it's totally shut off if there's trees
and stuff back here you'd be able to see
all the way through and it also creates
this false sense of depth so imagine
that this is the front door right so we
have our rather large windows this could
be the kitchen imagine that we've kind
of completed
these parts but that this is kind of
still open so you have a garden that's
kind of separating the public pieces of
the house from the more kind of private
pieces of the house that element has
actually also kind of worked its way
around out here
so with here you can kind of see the
depth so again we're trying to create
these connections through this way they
kind of stitched the building together
the conceptual and experience
point-of-view
so there is your markup for house my
house so this is like the living area in
this white block and this is the main
mass that's sort of providing shading
for the buildings I did leave a lot of
openings on this top portion to allow a
lot of like I'm imagining skylights and
things here so there's lots of like deep
light penetration so this is sort of
like a little car park area and then
this is just more to frame sort of like
a open courtyard that would be landscape
an outdoor area so all these yellow box
is my library that extends through the
entire site and it holds and brings the
whole house together and then the house
is not necessarily divided into living
rooms or dining rooms or bedrooms most
of the house feels like it's blank what
I'm imagining there that there's a big
piece of glass in here so that glass
allows you to look at the water here the
water singing have the Steve
figuratively come into the house back in
here is what I'm imagining is where you
enter from so this is a space where we
share our library that's a space where I
experience it only by myself no one
really else is allowed to go in there so
the library really does extend through
the whole piece and it's really
something that brings the experience
together
[Music]
you
[Music]